and we begin this morning with continued
fallout from a cruel comment made by a
White House aide about Senator John
McCain's terminal illness the staffers
words came after Senator McCain
expressed strong reservations about the
president's choice to head the CIA
yesterday McCain's family responded
while the White House did not it's
refusing to acknowledge that it was even
said but behind the scenes its damage
control Errol Barnett is at the White
House Erol good morning good morning
president Trump is here with no public
events on his schedule this weekend as
the firestorm over an aides comment
continues now the White House has issued
a statement thanking Senator John McCain
for his service but it has so far
refused to address or admonish the aides
insult I don't understand what kind of
environment you're working in when that
would be acceptable and then you can
come to work the next day and still have
a job
senator McCain's daughter Megan spoke
out against the White House at the
staffers dismissed her father over his
opposition to the president's CIA
nominee my dad's all about character and
bipartisanship and and something greater
than yourself and believing in this
country and according to sources White
House communications aide Kelly Sadler
joked in a staff meeting that McCain's
rejection of mr. Trump's CIA pick quote
doesn't matter
he's dying anyway McCain who is
undergoing treatment for terminal brain
cancer said he would oppose Gina Hass
Bulls nomination because of her
involvement in the CIA's enhanced
interrogation program saying quote her
refusal to acknowledge tortures
immorality is disqualifying I'm not
gonna comment on an internal on Friday
press secretary Sarah Sanders repeatedly
refused to acknowledge Sadler's comments
but confirmed that Sadler still had a
job McCain's wife Cindy tweeted directly
at Sadler quote may I remind you my
husband has a family seven children and
five grandchildren Sadler's remarks have
drawn condemnation from both sides of
the aisle
McCain's close friend Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham responded nobody is
laughing in the Senate and former Vice
President Joe Biden remarked
Cinci in the Trump administration has
hit rock bottom is that a war hero this
adds to the strained relationship
between McCain and President Trump who
questioned the Senators past during the
campaign he's a war hero because he was
captured
I like people that weren't captured
since taking office mr. Trump and McCain
have frequently clashed the Arizona
senator famously voting down a White
House led effort to repeal Obamacare we
have a respect for all Americans and
that is what we try to put forward in
everything we do both in word and in
action now Sadler has called Megan
McCain to apologize but it is unlikely
to change things even before this
incident the McCain family had told the
White House it wants vice president Mike
Pence to attend the Senators funeral if
and when that comes not president Trump
Anthony Errol Barnett at the White House
this morning Thank You Errol